Alexander klochenkov always has his
camera with him when he's out and about
in his hometown of narva on estonia's
eastern border
the Russian town of Ivan garod lies
across the river
NATO an EU member Estonia is connected
to Russia via a bridge
these days even less traffic than usual
is passing through here
that makes 36 year old pluchenkov sad
like most of narva's inhabitants he is
Russian
the war against Ukraine is a thorny
issue here
I think that most Russians who live here
in Estonia say this is our homeland but
there are many opinions here on this
Ukraine issue some are against it others
are for it there are Fierce discussions
especially on social media
many Russians here have relatives on the
other side they greatly distrust to the
Western media
many watch Russian TV channels in their
propaganda shapes the image of the
Ukraine war
after eight years of suffering and
donbass Russia has liberated these
territories from the Ukrainian
nationalists they just launched a
special Liberation operation if Russia
had not intervened the situation would
have only got worse
Alexander klochenkov does not
necessarily share these views but he
still believes it's good to follow
Russian news sources on the war in
Ukraine
it's important in this conflict to get
your information from different sources
you can only get information from
Russian TV stations but also not only
from CNN BBC or Deutsche Vela the truth
lies somewhere in the middle
but for most estonians and the
government the responsibility for the
war lies squarely with Russian President
Vladimir Putin
estonians these days are glad to be in
NATO this small country hopes that its
NATO membership were protected from
Russian aggression
Britain has increased the number of its
soldiers in Estonia
and on Independence Day in Thailand in
late February the country defiantly
displayed its Readiness to defend itself
the Estonian foreign Ministry says Putin
is probably trying to win over the
Russian minority in Estonia
but insists it has no doubts about the
Loyalty of the Russians in Estonia
no concerned with regards to any
Estonian citizens
but at the same time it is true the
divisions that we have within our
societies which are normal because we
are democracies these divisions
are always being used by those who
counter us I shall say but more and more
Russians in Estonia are distancing
themselves from Moscow in narva
estonians and Russians demonstrate
together in front of the Russian
Consulate General
members of the younger generation in
particular see themselves as estonians
of Russian descent and want nothing to
do with Putin's War
E
I am really shocked
I follow the news all day on various
kinds of media and all sorts of
different channels
I am shocked that in the 21st century
Wars are still possible in Europe
I think it will affect to everyone
because Putin will not stop all of this
and he already said that he will go to
them
my sister was born in 1940 during World
War II
my parents experienced the war too
my entire family was affected
none of us want war
we are against the war and against those
who started it
for Alexander kluchenkov there is no
question of taking part in any
demonstrations he believes that would
only create more unrest in narva he
prefers to concentrate on his work as a
photographer
the demonstration seem like theater
Productions to me
but of course it's still important for
people to express their opinions it's
always better to talk to have a dialogue
and not a warlock
enkov feels the same as most Russians in
Estonia they don't want to have to
choose between east and west and the war
in Ukraine has not changed that